at the animal foundation it is getting
harder to just drop off a stray or found
dog right away yeah appointments really
booked up quickly sometimes taking days
if not weeks to bring an animal that's
according to several rescue groups which
brought this new issue to our own
Victoria Saha and she explains how this
could be straining for some good
sense and rescue groups across
[Music]
after looking into these complaints
Tuesday morning and again Wednesday
morning it told me that the next
available appointment was on January
19th but then checking again this
afternoon after reaching out to the
animal foundation it shows Thursday with
the next available time slots and then
again January a big gap leaving many
wondering how this will affect the dogs
that need to be saved off the streets
the animal foundation one of the largest
shelters in the country but now
operating differently than in years past
you can't just show up to drop off a dog
you rescued off the streets I have a
leashes collars I have a emergency kit
Melanie Shane is a founder of doggy task
force Las Vegas rescuing dogs off
streets is her passion over the last few
weeks seeing an increase in dogs being
dumped inside of dog parks and tied to
poles earlier this week her team found a
dog and then she was told by the animal
foundation to come back in five weeks so
she called Animal Control it took two
days for animal control to pick up the
dog back in October the shelter had to
limit operations due to the spread of a
respiratory illness which caused a
strain on rescue groups the same strain
they say they're feeling again I've
never seen anything or heard of anything
like this before animal Advocate Bryce
Henderson says he is plan to hold a
rally against this soon it's like having
a hospital with a trauma center with a
five-week waiting period you really
don't have a Trauma Center then you know
and we don't really have a shelter the
animal foundation gets millions of
dollars in taxpayer money to operate as
an open admission shelter waiting five
weeks is not an open admission shelter
Henderson says it will be close to
impossible for lost pets to be reunited
with their owner if the delayed intake
appointments continue imagine if your
dog gets out tonight
and where are you going to go look for
it you can't go to the shelter I reached
out to the county and the city to see if
this new intake process is a violation
of their contract with the animal
foundation I'm told it's being looked
into Victoria Saha eight news now now as
for the appointments Victoria was told
that people do book and then cancel so
it opens up spots check a couple of
times a day as for their response in
taking in animals they sent this
statement the animal foundation is
testing a managed intake policy that
helps find the best possible outcome for
pets outside of these stressful shelter
environment the animal foundation
continues to accept an average of 44
pets daily since the implementation of
this program